good morning New Yorker looking for
another beautiful day here in the city
new class to start us off a steady
increase in sightings of spider-man has
sparked a national debate over the role
of vigilantism in American crime fight
how about that spider-man last night on
the Manhattan Bridge you saved a dozen
alive
we want to hear your call I think
without spider-man
and we no hope for this game who do you
think paid the bills lauded damages he
caused huh it's you and me tack Jesus
this is a wind turbine you make this no
way this is amazing
right I'll walk y'all what's in there
what orale
um come spider I don't feel like my kids
are safe with him out there get out of
the way and let the police do their job
some folks think that there might be
more than one spider-man what do you
think one guy or many I'd love to know
who's behind that man
Thanks outfit right we have a caller on
the line they met he does he know
spider-man listen I'm upset spider-man
to me is being misunderstood he's a very
very important he's protecting us not
only that he saved my life one time we
just sort of became best friends
how much you're that spider guy outside
a bid of spider-man you're spider-man
guy he's not the police he's not a
fireman what gives him the right to get
involved in other people's business
[Music]
you
you